foreign
thank you
foreign
hello
good morning
hello hello hello hello hello
welcome
I want there to be a weave in the DLC
okay then
interesting
how's everybody doing today
will the DLC cost money or be free
it will more than definitely cost money
unless it's like a free update
um
that'll likely be free well free update
obviously but an update will likely be
free
I would say any DLC depending on how big
it is will be twenty dollars
that's my guess I believe that's how
much Dark Souls 3 DLC cost it might cost
a little bit more now
uh because gaming is like increasing in
price I believe I think I'm not sure on
that one actually
we'll see
we don't know yet
but good morning hello everybody
happy
Tuesday right
everything's too it's Tuesday
they should give it to those three who
bought the more expensive version of the
game or something
was that a thing was there a more
expensive version
of the game
well there's the collector's edition but
you get a whole bunch of stuff for that
right
I'm guessing the colosseums will be
updated for free that's what I was
thinking too Samantha absolutely
well why is the shadow weird what the
[ __ ]
what the hell is wrong with the chat why
did this happen uh oh
sorry I look up at that it's like what
the
[Music]
uh
do we do chat today because this is why
is it like this it actually shouldn't be
refresh
you guys are stretching
like an apostle why is that happening
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
I actually don't know let's see
of course I have to fix things
of course of course
copy
and then let's just do
sorry boys and girls
nope that didn't work
that's worse actually
it's much worse
oh
no I don't have the randomizer on
[Music]
okay maybe we don't do chat today
you guys don't get to be on the screen
today why is it it actually has no
reason to be wide
you're just wide people happy right
you're just very expressive today
yep you're just stretching
feeling good there's actually no reason
for this to be a thing
in my thingy here
uh all right excellent
I'm actually going to get rid of it
and then we're gonna try again
because I like it when you guys are on
screen you're pretty cute
pretty cute guys
Bang
okay
keep typing
hey that's better
okay
now I think I want you to be a little
bit bigger
save
keep typing keep typing
hmm
oh I won't have the whatever
of course I'm not prepared
of course
okay we good
is that better is it stretched
let's go with like that right there does
that seem fine
okay I didn't mean spam [ __ ]
no it's not the stream it's the browser
Source or whatever what's up Stan how we
doing
thank God we have a mod
what is in the DLC we have no idea hello
this seems fine
okay
thank you Stan you know how much I don't
like using FaceCam but I think uh
people other people like it so I'll try
and do what people like
make it clap with no hands
uh no
foreign
you're gonna have to pay me for that
I will not do a duck face I refuse
this will not happen
um so what what I wanted to do today was
I don't know about you guys I have not
played Elden ring in a very long time
very long time
it's uh
I made the radagon video over two weeks
ago now and I didn't actually play the
game I just recorded
where I go to like a certain spot and I
actually hacked the game with mods to
like get things in certain places but I
haven't actually played the game
I would say in like a month or something
I would say a month or so I haven't
haven't even touched it
and other than recording the radagon
video
nothing
so
and I was like kind of wondering myself
like why is that and it's probably
because I'm burnt out like crazy you
know and I think like everybody else I
have like 500 and 50 hours in the game
I'm sure other people have more hours
than that but that's a lot of hours in
gosh seven months now six months
something like that
how's the story project going completely
on hold
did you guys not see vati's whole uh his
second Channel had a trailer for it I
don't know if he's released it yet or
not
um exactly what I was doing
so that really kind of I was like
that really took the the wind out of my
sails on that one
Pro Gamer gets new character ready for
Elden ring DLC
that that should be the title I like
that title
417 hours and still haven't finished a
single playthrough
well that's good that means you're very
thorough wolf in your exploration
I don't know um
what would I want to use
for the DLC whenever it comes out
I really enjoy strength builds a lot I
think they're the most fun
difficult
but fun
hmm
I don't know
I'll blow the wind in your sales thank
you Trey
thank you
600 hours and just got now all
achievements congrats
congrats I guess I should start with a
Wretch like I know what I'm doing it's
not gonna be that bad
should we go with the Giga Chad wretch
um
giga
yes indeed
after playing Ark survival evolved I
don't know with a lot of hours there
anymore
I'm the same way uh with the game I
played for a very long time and some of
you know this and most of you don't
if you had to guess how many hours do
you think I have in rocket League
just take a take a guess
the answer is too many but
how many
I'm going rich
3500 not even close
over a thousand not even close
one hour
you're colder Catwoman
6500 you're getting closer but not quite
it's a lot
okay not 10K 10k's Pro level
30 seconds colder
way more
okay it's not 10K you guys are you guys
are pretty much there I have 7 500 hours
in rocket League
2500 of those were on console
on Xbox
Xbox One and then about 5 000 hours on
PC
so about 7 500 hours 10K hours at this
point in the game's lifespan which is
about seven years
uh a long time now
he's about 10 000 hours if you want to
be a Pro Player 10 000 hours
that's what it takes insane I used to
play rocket League
10 hours a day when I was trying to be a
pro and then I couldn't be a pro because
honestly I'm too [ __ ] old
to be a Pro Gamer at this point
to be a Pro Gamer I'm too old
right up
I'm not sure if the Super Chat is
working I have not received one yet they
should be working
could be good sir
[Music]
no I know I'm a pro gamer
why did this happen
you guys are gone I lost you
I have no chat now
I'm sorry
this is my fault
[Music]
nope not what I wanted
foreign
[Music]
we're back
welcome back chat
there we go testing I like green beans
oh there's no voice over
pain
I like green beans too
good stuff
literally fighting radagon any tips
radagon's actually not that bad
once you learn his moveset just gotta
Dodge bro
just gotta Dodge what was I talking
about before I accidentally deleted chat
and had to go back to my studio
I went did I need the British guy
no
no British guy
I'll read your message
uh my first playthrough of Elden ring
was 250 hours I over leveled
overleveled 185 Merlin for Melania I
want to talk about that today I do
I do want to talk about that today
which is a part of the reason why I'm
making a new character but let me
actually get going here
stalling
I can't type a name oh [ __ ]
uh okay everybody hold
I'll be right back
Andrew
thank you for the five dollars Trey
thank you for the two dollars
good morning let's start this off with
some grilled cheese and some 777.
777
hold on
I gotta connect my keyboard to the other
computer
scuffed
that's me that's on me bro
7777 all right what's our name
sorry I didn't want to put my crotch in
the camera because my
my computers on the other side right
across the camera right here
and pretty much my crotch was in the
camera so I turned it off
yeah I know my name is Jake but what do
you want
this character
because we had Lord Vander we could do
another Rick
that could be fun
people pay big money for that I don't
know about that chief
I don't know about that
these Souls camera crotch
DLC Lord I like that
I actually like that
I'll do Rick
Rick DLC Lord
Thief queef excellent Andrew thank you
I appreciate
another two dollars man thank you very
much
Rick DLC Lord
excellent
Ricky Reagan
Giga Rick
this is fine it's not important
well let's get going here
because I believe a lot of you are
actually new to the soul series
and DLC
is very different in these games
which is why I'm starting a new
character
I'll explain that after this I want to
see it again
it's been a while
hi Christian
appreciate it man thank you
yeah I know some of you are veterans
you know how many new people are playing
the souls games
you're not wrong man
you're not wrong
the the DLC in these games are always
amazing always
shut up reichardt if Joy barks I want to
see her also never seen anything on this
game you've never seen Elgin ring oh my
God bro okay
yeah we're starting from scratch this
will this will be nice Luke thank you
for the five dollars
Joy's upstairs but if she comes
downstairs she'll be on camera she'll be
laying right there so we'll get her
we'll get her at some point thank you
Luke of the Newfound strength
trigger yeah so Elden ring is the first
Souls game for a lot of you guys we'll
talk about this I want to get into the
game
I remember when we started Dark Souls 3
people were like why is there an epic
cut scene for Dark Souls 3's intro and
Elden ring has
paintings
and I think I said they spent all their
money on the dark still dark souls 3
intro
they didn't have money yet when they
were making this rice now
you tarnished
you're dead oh you have to live
Dark Souls 3 is better I don't know
about that
yeah I just started Spartans to us all
that's a good idea Miro good stuff
thank you Luke
hold on
they all knowing
whoa
see I started with dark souls 3 too Luke
but then I played all the other games
and thank you again
I'm Gonna Keep thanking you I can't not
thank you
Grace what again you mean zoly the witch
James Sometimes I do yeah I don't really
watch
that much Elden ring content to be
honest
it's me
ant to stand before the Elden ring this
intro is very cool I love it
and become yep just started Mark welcome
Dark Souls 2 is such a regret
you've seen the new vati video not yet
not yet I will watch it though at some
point
I do very much enjoy his videos
it's probably incredible
people who make content tend to not have
much time watching other content it's
just too much you know it really is
uh sometimes you gotta step away
to uh
you know I don't know it's I think
that's a normal thing
I think that's normal
oh yeah this feels good
the legend of DLC it's Rick DLC Lord
we're starting a new Rick
I'm gonna do a uh
a strength build even though they're
usually not the best
oh it's because it crashed okay we're
good now excellent
I think I'm gonna do a strength build
I just enjoy them the most
yeah it has been a while
since I've played this game
feels good man
Good Start I always jump up on that
I always jump up on that rope and now
I'm I'm so bad I can't do it
I'm not used to being able to jump
zero deaths
[ __ ]
whatever
dude Rick's booty
looking pretty good
kill me sir excellent
get me out of here
do strength Faith to get those insane
Buffs
we'll see what it turns into
I was just thinking pure strength in
vigor
I hope everybody insinuated to have a
split identity horror Godfrey Saint
Trina Mikala
gets a DLC to help solidify some
information we're definitely
usually that's how DLC in these games
work
is we don't know nothing until we get
DLC and then it answers some questions
I seriously doubt that any any type of
DLC in this game the first DLC because I
believe there's gonna be multiple DLCs
for Alden ring
I seriously doubt they can answer all of
our questions in one DLC
I'm gonna say there's gonna be like
Fortune three to five DLCs for this game
probably around that
and then there will be never be an Elden
ring two
never
one of his kind is sure to seek the
Eldon ring
yeah horse armor would be cool I would
say that would just be an update
what up silly
beat the tree Sentinel
dog I haven't played this game in a
month you think I'm gonna beat the tree
Sentinel as a wretch
you're tripping
where is the lands between technically
and where is the place Godfrey was cast
off to
you I don't know
does anybody know that they're called
the Badlands but I don't know where that
is
I don't know where the lands between are
they're between something
okay we gotta go beat Rick and assert
our dominance as Rick
obviously
we're in Ohio good good call it's
exactly right we're in Ohio
yep
that's where it is
I don't know what comment I just read
but I regret reading it
I think the next Souls game will be
something so innovatively different I
agree
um I think the first thing we're gonna
get is armored Core
I'm pretty sure
we're gonna get armored Core
which I've never played in armor core
game before
and it will not be like these games at
all I think
Badland DLC has a bunch of horror horror
lose wrestling around like crazy
interesting
oh I got my big ass water jug I got my
morning protein shake
I'm drinking that right now
[Music]
all right Rick
let's get it
um
I'm the only Rick in this town
yeah
leave me alone
nerd
I'm the real Rick
Lord of DLC
I know he's just letting me win though
unfortunately
kind of ruins the moment
strength exactly that's what we're going
for
you know it'd be funny if they just
patched in without telling anybody
when you beat soldier of dodrick it says
godfeld
God that'd be funny just just to go with
the meme
everyone go nuts
he's actually a god
I still have the opinion that they're
getting off near is the villain
absolutely Gideon is a [ __ ]
a [ __ ]
not a fan of Gideon
Spence the lands between us and a fog
clearly it's in the sixth Archstone
from Demon Souls
I like that theory
yep
yep yep yep yep
all right how many of you think I can
beat the tree Sentinel like this
I don't think I can
dude I don't even think I gave myself
foreign
I'm really making this hard on myself
oh yes
yes tarnished
it's hot it's not weird
of course you have no shame in it I've
outcome you are fake blah blah blah
we've all heard it
your maidenless
you can definitely do it
hmm you guys are suggesting that
I'm good at the game
yeah it's got a little uh veggies in
there Trey
so it's a little green
did that not hit
my mom is dish
Bob
she's dancing around in the window
and I can't move
yep
yep
foreign
no I wanted to hit that
I didn't know when I charged with this
kind of goes nuts like that
foreign
let's go
might get stuck
oh no stamina no stamina
oh God
The Shield attacks scare me the most
and that one I don't like that one
either
yeah
that actually went quite well
all right the answer is no I can't do it
not a bad run though not gonna cap
are
no
dude first time I saw these goats roll
away
I was just like
um
interesting
why
I don't want to
pretty interesting take isn't it to not
want to
okay
so
looks like your milk has gone off guys
it's a protein shake it's a little green
there's some veggies in here there's
like the protein powder in it there's
it's water
it's fine
it's it's not milk there's no milk in
that at all
what's on the agenda for DLC prep
well
no I'm not
hole
I actually have been drinking more milk
but that's not milk
I live off caffeine and anxiety
I don't think caffeine helps with with
anxiety dog
I don't think so
what's up Cole how are you doing man
dude have you have any of you just I'm
just gonna talk today have you guys
played OverWatch yet or OverWatch 2 is
anyone trying that game at all
I picked up those didn't I
you're a tarnished
I can see it but I can also see
that you're not after my thing I wonder
why he knows that we're tarnished
[Music]
not currently
I tried it
just to
because I haven't played OverWatch since
like 2016 right super long time
I was like
I'm gonna give OverWatch to a shot see
if it's fun I heard they changed it from
6v6 to 5v5 and I'm like okay
I gave it a try I've been non-stop
playing OverWatch
non-stop it's actually super fun
very surprising very fun
so far
apparently OverWatch porn is a thing
yes it is is it better than valorant I
mean I haven't played Valerian in a long
time either so
Jesus Christ where's the OverWatch
stream
you guys wouldn't watch me play
OverWatch bro
you wouldn't I wouldn't say I'm good at
it but I have fun playing it
goodbye for now all right let's go get
torrent
I am disgustingly naked apparently
it's a fun game when you're winning I
feel like that's everything right it's
not exactly fun when you're not winning
with anything
I'm gonna go in here first
just play mystery Heroes don't bother
with the other modes I haven't tried
that yet I've just been doing I have to
do a quick play
you have to win like 50.
you have to I think it's 30. it's either
30 or 50 quick play matches to even play
uh competitive
losing's more fun than winning I don't
know about that chief
Bonk
the Bonks are in boys the Bonks are in
so many moves
it was really banking on the Stagger
there of some kind
like that
I will not die to you I refuse
nerd
foreign
build
could we go all in with a bonk build
like where's the larger version of this
weapon
let's just go with the Bonk build that
seems fun
just the biggest Club I can have all
strength all vigor
in stamina just have the biggest armor
set biggest Club
biggest health bar and just go for it
bro
yeah where's the I think it's either the
troll or the tree Club
or the giant Crusher we could do that
too
whatever we can get first
yeah let's just fat roll
through everything
a chunky build
I haven't done that yet
okay I think there's nothing else
the sir Bonk build
um
it feels good playing this game again
I'm not gonna lie it really has been a
while
like the base game I know we did the
randomizer like three weeks ago but
that was like playing a whole other game
it was really fun
I got thick legs they look good
nobody likes skinny legs bro donkey legs
for the bomb
that'd be fun Krusty I've I have not I
have yet to touch PVP in this game not a
single time have I done any type of PVP
it's too much like [ __ ] around it I
don't know or like I guess the way
people were talking about it
made me just like not want to do it I
guess
that's a good name Fork
definitely didn't say it right
orius has left the chat
rip
greetings
Traveler
from Beyond the fog
I am melaner
I think the first DLC is gonna surprise
people
I don't know what it is but I don't
think it's gonna be like mikola or
the Badlands I really don't think it's
gonna be that offer you an accord
I think I might have something to do
with her because she's like the person
we talk to the most in the game for the
most for the most part
because we really don't know that much
about this chick
like set in stone information offering
guidance
south of forlorn Hound evergail
got it I know where that is
I can play the role of Maiden
turning runes into strength
to Aid you yeah everybody wants Godwin
everybody wants Michela
you need only take me with you I don't
think it's gonna be that right away it
probably involve all of it but I like
the main theme I don't think is gonna be
that
summon me pre-shattering DLC would be
great
that would be great oh
troll Steed use it to Traverse great
distances
it will summon a spectral steed
named torrent
torrent has chosen you
treat him with respect
so that is the girl from Dark Souls 3
the the queen who was sitting in
in Orlando somewhere yeah like near in
Orlando and Dark Souls 3. that's the
voice actor exactly the same
how would they throw you back in time
[ __ ] I don't know
like it's gonna be
I mean how did we go back in time with
the dragonlord you know I mean like I
don't know
anybody know how that happened nope
probably not
shall I turn your room
s drag let my hand i'm leveling Vigor
first I can level once we're going from
level one to two
let's [ __ ] go boys
let's go
level two
we are really looking good out here all
right
let's go get our seeds
let's go get our sacred tears let's go
do all the [ __ ] that is required
foreign
but I do want to talk about
probably the reason
why all of you could probably start a
new character
and it's mainly for the DLC because I'm
assuming all of you are going to play
the DLC
probably
I don't know how you how you feel about
this game for the most part
you must like it somewhat even if maybe
you haven't beaten the game
foreign
oh yeah you can just Sprint right past
that giant easy peasy
okay CD boy
okay
let's go back
over here grab the map and then go the
other way
I love the ring that is Elden
let me make it daytime
yeah you actually can run past anything
in all of these games
level 150 is where I am with all the
characters so I think I'll be ready for
the DLC well there's a point I'd like to
make with that that's that's good
are you on
New Game Plus or or no like your
character is just level 150.
where am I going past time warning
bold you assume I even have this game
you're watching me play it so like I
assume you have the game
no not New Game Plus then you should be
okay
I I don't so here's the thing about what
I'm about to talk about
is the fact that it's kind of preference
on how you want to experience the DLC
I
me personally I want to experience the
DLC in its default difficulty and it's
in its original like how they design the
fight to be because the first
playthrough of anything whether it's the
DLC or the main game or whatever it is
in all of these games they're like a
sacred thing that can get they can get
messed up pretty quickly
so
you're I'll keep it it's it's not too
hard to explain
it is it's definitely your preference on
how you want to experience the DLC
because
usually in all of these games
they put the DLC in a unique spot
they don't just you don't just press
play on the DLC and you go immediately
and play the thing
you sometimes have to go find it they'll
give you information on how to find it
but it's gonna be somewhere random in
the world and then you're going to be
put somewhere else
I would think just based on the
the past games and how they've released
their DLC
they're gonna put the game or they're
gonna put the DLC
somewhere in the middle of your
playthrough it's not gonna be at the end
it's not going to be at the it could be
at the beginning I don't know
um
but it's going to be somewhere in the
middle of it it's not gonna be you know
you need to be level 150 or level 200 to
even get through the DLC it's probably
not gonna be that so based on your
preference
how you want to experience it like if
you just want to run through the DLC
really quick then you've got your level
150 200 character you go demolish
everything
you get that experience whatever for me
I don't really want that I want to have
the default experience so how I'm
getting this character ready
is I'm probably gonna go I think what
Miro said in the chat earlier is I'm
probably only gonna go to about morgot
and then I'm gonna stop
I might play a little bit more just to
level up a bit more
but I don't want to over level so I I
don't overpower the DLC that they create
does that make sense
I'm running right past Bach
it could be on like we don't really know
per se
the other part of this
is for uh people who have one character
and they're on New Game Plus
you're already kind of messing with the
difficulty when you go into New Game
Plus like
correct me if I'm wrong but New Game
Plus
the enemies hit you a bit harder and you
lose Health a bit quicker like what what
is the what really happens in DLC
I don't know the specific thing
there's no news on it yet mug it would
be around
it would either be sooner or next year
like what what exactly happens when you
you go into New Game Plus
around 75 I I think so captain
does anyone know specifically like I
don't want to guess here I should have
looked it up
so you have one save and it's new game
plus six so this what I'm talking about
right now is mainly for you because I
think a lot of people are on New Game
Plus runs and they have one character
if you're in new game plus six and you
go into the DLC you're gonna be on new
game plus six DLC
it it will it will change it's it's not
gonna be like that James it's If You're
A New Game Plus
it's gonna be new game plus whatever the
number for your DLC experience which is
something I don't want I want to have
the default what from software designed
and how much damage they do the default
experience whereas like two or three of
my other characters are on new game plus
three or whatever so that's why I'm
making a new character and I think
that's why you should too
if you haven't played the game in a
while or you only have one character at
new game plus whatever you should
probably think about leveling a
character to about 75 maybe a hundred
um so that you can beat Melania I don't
I don't know exactly where the DLC is
gonna be but like I said just based on
how the other pass games have done DLC
it's gonna be somewhere in the middle of
the game the middle of the experience so
I'm gonna try and have that most genuine
default experience that from software is
going for
and
I think I'm gonna have a better
experience with it but that's my
preference like I've been saying like if
you just want to roll through it and
that's your experience good for you
um if you want to experience the DLC on
new game plus six
go for it man like
that's that's fine you you can do that
but
that's not the experience that I want to
go for when I'm playing the DLC
does that make sense
I'm bad enough it'll be hard anyway then
that's fine
that's fine
what if they make the DLC scale to
in-game stuff then you can go to your
main character
this is more like the reason I'm making
a new character is just in case
because here's what's going to happen
I I'm a little bit scared of this exact
situation happening
DLC is gonna release
and there's a whole bunch of people
in
hello
there's a whole bunch of people
that are new to these games
that don't know how DLC Works in these
games it's very different from past from
other games
because sometimes they place them in the
middle so like with dark souls 3 DLC the
first DLC was about halfway through the
game and it scaled to halfway through
the game do I think they're gonna do
that with Elden ring
I don't know that's why I'm being
cautious in making a new character
I would say if you if you leveled a new
character all the way up to Melania then
you're gonna be fine
which I
what is that level 100 maybe level 90
for Millennia I'm not sure
I think I fought her at like 75 and I
got my [ __ ] Rock for five hours and then
I finally beat her
isn't it a little early for a new
character for DLC I don't know we
haven't received any information
but
they usually release DLC for their past
games I'm going based off all the past
stuff all of their past games which I
think makes sense to go off what they've
created before and how they sort of
handle these things right
it could be very early for me to make a
DLC character I'm just kind of getting
it ready I think people do that in World
of Warcraft right like they prepare for
new expansions
that's kind of what I'm doing
so
with bloodborne their first DLC released
in no when was it I don't know about
bloodborne actually when did DLC release
from bloodborne compared to the the
initial release of the game
for Dark Souls 3
they release DLC in October when the
game released in March
which is now
with bloodborne nine you guys are saying
nine or eight eight months we're getting
pretty close to that
so I think I think it's coming if it's
gonna come it's gonna come soon
if it's not it's gonna be mid next year
which yes could be a little early for
this but
I'm just I'm being cautious I want to
have uh I want to have my character
ready to go for it
yes the math the math adds up
but here's what I here's what I wanted
to say real quick there's a lot of new
people in these from software games
playing that don't understand what we've
been just talking about right they're
completely new to the franchise and they
only know Eldon ring so they're on new
game plus six
they've got a character that's level 400
and they haven't even beat the game yet
so
they're gonna get the DLC that they're
gonna pay for probably 20 to 30 dollars
for this DLC
they're gonna go into it and they're not
gonna have the experience that they
thought they had or
they're not gonna get the experience
that they thought they were gonna have
like they did in their first playthrough
when they were leveling through the game
and they're gonna get pissed they're
gonna go on Twitter they're gonna start
some [ __ ] on Reddit they're gonna be
like well this is just so I had such a
bad experience and I can't have this
first experience ever again
I see it coming people are gonna get mad
because they haven't played other games
they don't know how the DLC works
hopefully this is making sense
though I don't want people to have a bad
taste in their mouth
oh let me stop let me not eat with my
mouthful or talk with my mouthful
sorry
higher level players will blow through
the DLC quickly and then complain that
it wasn't enough
exactly what I'm saying there's gonna be
people out there and you know these
people exist it they're they're out
there man
they're gonna be level 500 or whatever
the hell
they're gonna go into the DLC and be
completely disappointed they're like
this wasn't difficult at all probably
because you were level 500 they start
arguing people start arguing it goes on
forever it's super [ __ ] annoying you
know what I'm saying
does this make
it's it's so hard to explain this [ __ ]
so hopefully it's making sense
all I know is that the DLC will be great
you're absolutely right the DLC is
always the best content in all of their
games dude maybe aside from Ash's of
Aryan doll
I like Dash's very indel in Dark Souls
3. ring city was clearly better but I
really enjoyed all of it it's always
good dude always good
okay well hopefully yeah hopefully I'm
making sense I'm hoping to go in a bit
under level for the DLC and take my time
with the bosses and properly learn and
appreciate them if that's the experience
you want to go for then you should get
ready for that and I'm kind of warning
all of you now that you should get ready
for it
pickle Rick
I hope the DLC is post or during the
time of the shattering so you can talk
to some of the bosses like radon Melania
godric michalo radagon would be epic the
pickle Lord is anxious
I would love that too man I'm just not
entirely sure what they're gonna go for
they could go down any route with this
DLC we've been talking about that for
months at this point you know like all
of the potential DLC routes that from
software could take with this game
um
so I don't know what they're gonna do
but whatever they decide it's gonna be
sick I I know it and I do hope it's
pre-shattering before everything went to
hell and we can talk to like Queen
America like you were saying that would
be amazing that's exactly what I want I
don't know if it's what we're gonna get
but that would be cool
that would be cool
oh another another good point and Rick
thank you for the ten dollars I really
appreciate all your support dude thank
you
I understand your theory but Elven ring
is kind of different from other Souls
games maybe DLC too it is different I
get what you're saying I just I don't
want there to be any type of setup
for people to
to just start bitching about the DLC and
how their experience wasn't good
when there's there's not going to be any
warning for what I'm talking about it's
not going to be there there's
you know it could be extremely difficult
and needs you to be level 120 plus or
whatever
or not
I'm going based off the past games past
experiences because that's kind of what
happened to me when I played Dark Souls
3.
I was super overpowered I was new game
plus seven on Dark Souls 3 when ashes of
Arendelle came out
so my experience was completely
different to how a default experience
would be through the game
so
you know it I guess what you would
actually really want to do is wait for
DLC to come out
and then start a new character but this
game is different from the past games
like you're saying
so what I'm suggesting is that you guys
should prepare yourselves for the DLC
and not want to start a new character
when the DLC comes out because this game
is absolutely [ __ ] massive it takes a
long time to get everywhere that you
want to go it takes a long time to get
all the items that you need for the
weapons that you want stuff like that if
you want that proper default experience
which is preference like like I've been
saying
you know you know
I'd love three dlc's mid-level late game
and post game difficulty that would make
the most sense yes
they're probably think you know they're
thinking about this stuff they really
are
so we'll see
I'm just based off past games like I've
been saying a bunch of times now
I I think there's gonna be a setup here
for people to be upset and obviously I
don't want that to be the case you know
so I'm gonna try and get out there
quickly like hey guys you might want to
start a new character
maybe just to prepare yourself
I just want a battle pass do you really
want to battle pass guys
laughs
you guys really want a battle pass man
I just want to talk to America me too
that would be cool
that would be nice
what if they put
what if they put is before the
shattering you can change that to a
different ending no lands between
you're right so we can come up with all
of these hypothetical things
as to what the L what the uh
we can come up with all these
DLC predictions
what I'm suggesting this is all I'm
saying is that you might want to start a
new character
so that you could prepare yourself for
whatever happens you know what I'm
saying
so like if it turns out you want to be
level 150 you got a character right
there you're ready to go if it turns out
it's supposed to be mid game then you
have a character right there ready to go
for that if you need to be whatever the
hell
400 you got a character ready to go for
that
do you think they would connect Elden
ring with other games to the DLC
if that's the route they want to go they
definitely can as of right now there's
no reason to think about
there are some
but it's not uh
I don't think the games are connected
until they proved to me otherwise
as of right now the games are not
connected
DLC is the Elden past and tarnished
sense
yes indeed that would be great
you gotta you gotta buy another currency
of Eldon bucks
to buy the battle pass you guys are
great I love it here
the other thing to think about
is I wonder
if the endings will change
based on how you play the DLC I don't
know if they're gonna add more endings
or
the way you play a DLC will affect an
ending
but you know you just gotta prepare
yourself through all of this to you know
make sure your experience doesn't get
trashed
which I think people will complain about
anything and everything
so I'm just throwing this out there
I want Muriel's story too Austin that's
a good idea
Rick thank you dude holy [ __ ]
you are nuts with the super chats man
thank you very much
Die Hard fans will always find something
to be upset about because it isn't Dark
Souls you just gotta go in with an open
mind and see the beauty absolutely I
totally agree with you
I think Die Hard fans only want
I mean
oh
Die Hard fans want people
to have the experience that they had
that made them die hard fans right and
if people don't get that experience they
don't usually go on to play these games
for very long and especially play the
older games right which is mainly what
Die Hard fans want is for you to
experience all these games because for
me as a die-hard fan
they're all so incredible they're all
amazing
except Dark Souls 2 I don't like it
that's my that's my preference I just
don't like Dark Souls 2. you can like it
I just don't
what I want from the DLC is to answer
some [ __ ] questions about the
lore in this game
because press one in chat if you are
still majorly confused on how the lore
Works in this game
because I'm sorry we can we can really
go in depth on all the lore and and talk
about it to an endless extent
of course but it doesn't
it's so hard it's not clear there's so
many questions that I have
that I think a 1.5 is a good answer
where like some things we know and some
things just make absolutely no sense to
everything else it's it's hard
Devin
420 69. okay
Stan have you even played this game you
don't even know what you're talking
about
sorry I want to finish my Apple
I'm not going to eat the core of the
Apple
foreign
I know guys
were you saying like there's a ton of
lore if you take the time to do all the
reading
I've done that I've read all the [ __ ]
I've read everything in this game
multiple times I promise you
I promise it's so much [ __ ]
information
there is still a lot out there
that doesn't make sense
until we get an explanation on it that's
what I'm referring to there is a lot of
lore in this game that is that is told
to us and it does make sense
there's just as much that doesn't and
that's the stuff I'm talking about
there's a lot that does and there's a
lot that doesn't
so
okay I'm done with the Apple now
why does the turtle pope wear a hat
why
where's the little nightmare stream
we'll play it this week I promise
we'll play it
listening to your stream makes having to
work a lot better that's why I like
streaming during the day a lot of you
guys have told me that
so I'm gonna stream when you guys
appreciate it so thank I'm I'm glad
thanks for watching
just doing the super chat so you can
order a takeaway with twenty dollars not
having my boy go hungry I just ate an
Apple Man I'm good but if I wanted to I
could now so thank you bro I appreciate
it
yet again
thank you man
thank you pickle
you're a true legend
listening to your stream makes me not
want to do my schoolwork
dude [ __ ] School
I don't want to go on a rant about
school right now I really don't
but [ __ ] School
I'm sorry at least in the U.S [ __ ]
School
hello
all Popes are slow is that I don't know
about that
bomb
hey you can quote that for me dude [ __ ]
school it's dumb
it doesn't make any sense the the [ __ ]
that we learn for no reason
yeah I don't know about schools anywhere
else but at least in the US they're
trash
absolutely
Jake if you don't beat Margaret first
try we make a McDonald's order for you
deal
a McDonald's order I do like McDonald's
I do like McDonald's hmm
[Music]
the [ __ ] you learn does make sense okay
I guess I'm referring to more High
School
yes I like McDonald's I think if you get
certain things from there it's good
I really do
they are good
okay have I leveled at all where did you
guys say the big Club was that I can't
wield so what's the point of holding it
do I gotta go beat market like this
what do you mean I use the quadratic
formula this morning you mean x equals
negative B plus or minus the square root
of B squared minus 4AC all over 2A that
formula
x equals negative B plus or minus the
square root of B squared minus 4AC all
over 2A
ingrained in my [ __ ] mind dude
ingrained it'll never get out
what does it do
I don't know
I have no idea
but I know the formula
you just made up those words x equals
negative B plus or minus the square root
of B squared minus 4AC all over 2A you
think I made that up three times
no
the only thing good for McDonald's is
the trash can that the food belongs on
okay buddy
okay I like McDonald's not a lot but
sometimes
how many times did you use that in real
life that's my point not a single time
never
I I guess if I was a mathematician
where I need to use the quadratic
formula to figure something out
potentially
other than that ah
I don't know
okay let's go beat up the Giant in the
cave and get uh upgrade material
burn the witch you guys think I'm
summoning something
oh exactly
you study computer science do you use
the quadratic formula in that
why are they so popular if trash is
McDonald's or if McDonald's is trash
um I think some of their food is trash
I wouldn't recommend eating it a lot
because I think it'll eventually kill
you
I think it'll kill you if you eat too
much McDonald's
but
it's good when he got a little craving
for it and you just go get you know a
meal a month or whatever
born to play forced to go to school with
a fortnight picture
that's [ __ ] funny Garrett
that is hilarious
I was watching spooky videos earlier in
some disembodied voices from
they sounded like we're you're calling
math
kind of like that
that's kind of creepy
sir
stop it
wait you can get a smithing Stone from
these guys
or was that just luck
I actually don't know if I can beat the
giant at this level
this is going to be quite hard
it's an early farming it's definitely an
early farming dungeon for sure I didn't
know you could get them from these guys
though
[Music]
the Bonk is real
way better than my Katana against these
guys that's for sure
sir okay buddy
I will oh God
stop it
we're doing a bonka build Mr Reed
we're gonna get a big Club we're gonna
level our strength our Vigor our stamina
and we're gonna be just an absolute
Menace
to society
that's what I want to play the DLCs
a big Bonker
the big Bonk
we're gonna beat that booty
could be fun
what ending do you think it'll follow
uh none of the endings at all none of
them
it'll just explain more of the endings
hopefully
the answer to everything we've been
talking about like DLC wise is like a
big I don't know you better get yourself
ready or you're you're gonna you're
gonna have to work a lot harder to get
the experience that you want in the DLC
foreign
hell yeah
dude
the balk is real
oh here he goes
gonna have a temper tantrum
foreign
let's go
let's go bro
is there anything else in here no there
is not
that's what she said what did I say
I don't even remember
okay so we have some more Rooney boys
now
I don't know guys to everything we just
talked about
what do you guys think I'm curious
because maybe I'm up maybe I'm
overthinking the whole thing too much I
could very much be the case
I'm just curious what you all think
have you watched breaking the bad do you
mean Breaking Bad
yeah it's one of the best shows of all
time
what are you most hoping for in the DLC
um that we get DLC this year that's what
I want I don't care what it is we could
go into depth on the [ __ ] snails and
I'll be all about it
I'll be all about the snails man if
that's what the DLC is I just want I
want more
give me more now
more now please
you agree with me it sounds reasonable
makes sense
okay hope you know I I
you know I'm always just trying to make
sense and and get your guys take on
stuff because I could be completely
wrong
probably after a year that will get DLC
yeah
pretty true
Maybe
hmm
you know what's very surprising to me
is anyone else surprised that they
haven't at least updated the coliseums
yet
to like have PVP in those or whatever
I feel like we were talking about that
four months ago and nothing they haven't
done anything yet
I find that very strange
I feel like that's such an easy update
to get people at least some people back
into the game again
because I mean look look at this guys
I actually have these ready because I
knew I was gonna talk about this okay
what's this one look at this look at
this dude
this is worldwide
Google Trends of Eldon ring of people
just being interested in the game
it was at its peak when it came out
obviously and now I couldn't couldn't be
lower it's like the game isn't even out
yet
they're you know they beat the game and
they're done which makes which totally
makes sense
they beat the game
and now they don't want to they're done
playing it they're waiting for more
stuff
so
yes this graph is very very normal
but you guys know that there would be a
little rise in this graph if they
you know put out the update for the
Coliseum PVP
people would come back and they'd they'd
try that especially if they put like
ranked in this game somehow I don't know
like that sounds really difficult in
these games
uh
that just seems like such an easy win to
have out there you know like open the
coliseums
and have ranked PVP like that's how you
get players playing the game is you have
a multiplayer with a competitive system
if you want this graph to like shoot up
to at least halfway and stagnate it
halfway
looking good
what are the other graphs I have
I mean look at this
is just Steam
I would say the equivalent of steam is
probably PlayStation and Xbox combined
maybe I think so
but it's just increasingly down
every every month
I have not watched JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure
no I have not
implementing true seamless Co-op would
keep people interested
yeah usually people who are on console
play with their friends whereas PC
players are kind of loners a bit
um where you know only the PC people who
download a mod to their computer can do
the seamless Co-op and it is extremely
fun if they implemented that
for console and everybody I think this
the graphs of all these things would go
up
they really would
but they have not touched the game
except for some balancing issues since
it came out which I think is just so
very surprising
it just you know seems like easy wins
and they're just not doing it
show some more graphs
okay
um I have one more graph actually
I think it's just the no not that one
not that one
what is this Elden Rings platinum trophy
stat is shockingly high
I mean this is when you do all the
achievements in the game right that's
that's Platinum
for PS5 so everyone's beating the game
and they have beaten it
all the content that you can possibly do
in the game they have done it I've done
it I have every achievement in the game
shockingly High uh percentage of people
who play on at least PS5 where the
platinum trophy stat is
have beaten the game to all of its
content and yet
nada so I guess when you just beat the
entire game you don't really have a
reason to keep playing it unless you
update your games which
they have not been doing
then again it's a
it's a single player game
I I don't know like I did expect more I
really did
uh especially at this point to be
released at least
something
mainly the coliseums I thought that
would be a thing months ago at this
point it's still not
getting all the achievements is not hard
and it doesn't take long either are you
okay
I feel like it takes a lot of time
yeah you're plating a bit and just
waiting on the DLC exactly
we want the DLC baby let's go
please and thank you
oh I think Ronnie's gonna yell at me
Yep this way tarnished may I have a word
it took me 150 hours of platinum that's
a lot right it's a lot of hours man
I am the witch
I'd heard tale of a tarnished hurking
about Atop A spectral Steed and upon
looking into the matter the talk
Platinum is 7.8 on Steam right now
Dark Souls 3 is only 3.7 there you go I
mean well
that's actually extremely impressive
because
how many players in total played Dark
Souls 3 and the percentage is still that
low whereas there's way we already like
we know that there's way more players
playing Elden ring and the percentage is
that much higher anyway
that's good that means hey that means
they made a bomb game
we're not we're all not denying that
like they Eldon ring is a [ __ ] W of a
video game absolutely
just you know give me some updates
please
and thank you
hi Krusty
the coliseum's not being updated yet
makes me afraid we aren't getting DLC at
all that's something they could have
patched at launch
I mean if you guys have been in my
streams
over the past month or so
I've had the theory as well that we may
not get DLC ever with this game
potentially I was not done with my Apple
which would be the dumbest thing ever
it'd be the worst business decision of
all time
again me
but all the same
learn well the lands between
how long will it be I wonder before the
tarnished Tire of a basins to the two
fingers
Ronnie's voice acting is on another
level it's so [ __ ] good
I like listening to her
tell me what to do mommy
DLC is certain for sure I can't see from
software being that stupid business-wise
here's why I'm bringing that up and why
I've thought this
on why there could potentially not be
DLC with this game
bloodborne and Sakira
bloodborne
one of people's most favorite games of
all time millions of people love
bloodborne
it had one DLC
and it it's still at 30 frames per
second
they could put out a 60 FPS patch for 60
dollars and everybody would buy it just
for how good it is we might complain
that that's kind of a you know kind of a
lot
but I would pay it I'd do it
I would
it's that good of a game
that's an easy dub that's an easy
millions of dollars if they make it ten
dollars they will make millions of
dollars
if they put bloodborne on PC if they
made it 60 frames per second if they
updated the game in any way shape or
form for however much money they wanted
they could do that I think there's some
legal things going on with bloodborne
right now but I'm not 100 on that
that is an easy dub and they did not do
it
sakiro another example
sakuro won game of the year in 2019 was
very successful video game that
everybody loves the combat system of
everyone loves the story of it
no DLC for Sakura in three years nothing
besides a Bosch Rush Gauntlet which is a
cool update but was free
and have not touched the game since
maybe it didn't need DLC maybe
bloodborne didn't need more DLC but this
kind of goes to my point
I don't think from software gives a [ __ ]
about money
I don't think they care
so while Eldon ring in the in making DLC
for for it might be just the easiest dub
business wise
I don't think they care
they want to make quality ass video
games
that's all they care about quality over
quantity
and yeah it depends on the Publishers as
well like Activision Sony I'm sure
there's a lot going on there especially
with bloodborne not being on PC because
that's an easy dub put that out for 60
bucks on PC that's tens of millions of
dollars guaranteed
guaranteed tens of millions of dollars
but
nothing
with how massive Elder ring is and how
successful it is I don't think it's
crazy they can do all of that they
absolutely can
it is super successful
in fact I believe I remember reading a
I remember reading an article where
Elden ring blew away their expectations
they expected 2 million sales and I
believe the first month based on their
previous games and they sold 14 million
I think it's at 16 million now
blew away their expectations
they may have just made enough money
with this game man they want people to
keep talking about it and theorizing on
everything because that's kind of how
these games work
so yeah
so I don't I don't think from software
really cares
um
to to explain everything to make new
content for their games
in uh Miyazaki has said many times that
he doesn't like making sequels to games
the only reason Dark Souls 3 exists is
because Dark Souls 2 exists that's it
dark souls 3 would have never existed if
Dark Souls 2 didn't exist which he had
no involvement in at all
I think some involvement but he was not
the creative director
lore wise how would you even be even
continue the story knowledge ring like
we've been saying there's so many
different routes that who knows what
they'll choose
now do I think that they will make DLC
of course
they I think they will they've like you
said uh Ahmed
they've made DLC for all their previous
games except for sakiro which
was their game of the year which Elden
ring come on guys it's gonna win game of
the year
unless Ragnarok
Elden ring should win game of the year
agreed it should it probably will it's
akiro won game of the year and it was
like their [ __ ] side project
while they were working on eldering so
my point on that is I don't think Chrome
software cares about the business they
don't care about how much money they
make because they know that whatever
they put out is a [ __ ] banger
they could just make another game that
has nothing to do with Elden ring could
be another sakuro another bloodborne
like type of game not bloodborne 2 or
Sakura 2 but a whole other game
they know they make bangers that's all
they do people are gonna buy it they
want the quality experience
that's all they care about
that's the point
I still think they're going to make DLC
of course
I hope they do
but I don't think it's out of the realm
of possibility that they don't
that's all
this is mostly just a talking stream I
haven't done [ __ ]
I'm cool with it
a bloodborne 2 announcement would break
the internet it would literally be the
only thing people talked about
I've said this a few times on stream as
well
I think bloodborne 2
would sell better than eldering
I do
okay I'll get the Whetstone I saw you
say that earlier too sorry
Goosey
yeah they could announce 60 FPS update
or a remaster and that would be the
number one thing people talk about
at this point game of the year would
probably go to Ragnarok due to no
important things going into Eldon ring
listen
if God of War is as good as it was in
2018 Eldon ring will win game of the
year
that's my uh personal opinion on that
I forgot how to play this game holy [ __ ]
ball up at The Knocks
gray Wins Game of the Year I did enjoy
stray I played it uh on my own I did
like it
stray is very good but it's not better
now than ring I'm sorry
I just don't see Ragnarok being better
than God of War 2018.
I think that'll that'll be hard to pull
off
but they could
all right this is gonna be a
level six
Market try
with Roger
God of War is better how do you know
that it's not out yet
oh I should go I can't I can't wield it
yet print I gotta get room I got a level
Bonk activate
hey cats are cute cats are cute
The Last of Us One
you mean last it was two
I thought God of War One game of the
year did it not
did it lose to last of us too
I disagree with your opinion seven but
you can have that opinion absolutely
it wasn't the same here
oh that was in 2020 you're right Red
Dead 2 lost a game that's right I got
you
Roger you want to get involved
here we go
boxer in gentlemen
I'm doing no damage
probably because I use Roger
foreign
for absolutely nothing
you and your delayed swings Market
stop it
get him in the back
I
gotta do my Roar
man
the staggers I'm getting are crazy
look at this
the critical box
foreign
[Music]
get in there brother
okay how hard is he by himself
it was going so incredibly well
and then did not
in an instant
[ __ ]
foreign
it's not much better
whoa
we're definitely doing the damage
hmm
yeah why doesn't he fall off but I can
that's not fair
fish
not good
no not again
that's what I want
foreign
is here
look at that Pro Gamer moves
let's go
definitely possible
unless he starts doing some [ __ ]
which we know is gonna happen it's gonna
happen guys
[ __ ] will occur
that was the attack I was scared of
there it is you didn't do it the entire
time
this is hard
is there any news about elderly DLC or
is this just hopeful thinking I mean you
can go back and see what we talked about
but there is no news currently
okay I'm gonna use Roger
I think he he provided a great
distraction
foreign
worth the distraction
not good
Roger get involved
that hit me by the way
that hit
foreign
yeah we will be watching
the game awards on stream by the way
absolutely
no
get him get him get him
oh yeah we are gonna cringe at the game
awards but it'll be fun
can Roger not fall off either
all right
foreign
no I always get hit by the last freaking
attack bro
come here
can I get a stagger potential
gotta clutch up I don't think it's gonna
happen
we gotta clutch up
I didn't clutch up
dude wretch is hard I guess there's so
much other stuff I could go off and do
that are a lot easier than this but
wasn't very good I don't see God of War
being a game changing as Elden ring was
I don't either I think I think gay God
of War is going to be incredible like
it's going to be a great game
I don't think it beats Elden ring though
get a bleed weapon no
no
the answer is no
that's all
I would like to Bonk
the Bonks are more fun
we are assaulting this man in the corner
right now
all out assault
foreign
I did it too late
or too early
okay the tides have turned
I'm dead
it's so dark in this corner man
no Roger get him get him get him give
him get him nice
nice
not fair unfair
rip Roger
bruh calm down oh my God
that's the opposite of calming down the
opposite of that
dodging on point
foreign
I feel like I could bait this attack
just a bunch of times
that was nice
not lucky at all all skill
all skill
way too greedy
way too greedy
we can do it
[Music]
the greed
I I thought
I thought we were so close to a stagger
that I just went for it
I I just went for it
we had to have been close to a stagger
lime Rancher 2 is gonna be game of the
year
I hope so that sounds fun
my ambitions were put to rest
my Flame was extinguished
Roger you're being a [ __ ] right now
there we go I just had to call him a
[ __ ] real quick
foreign
okay
I'm trolling
Roger get the thing stop doing that get
the thing [ __ ]
maybe Roger does all the stacking
all the Staggering I thought I just
jumped off the map
my character just didn't dodge
foreign
than without I think it's gonna be
easier without Roger
you didn't press the button listen I
pressed the button it just didn't do it
it's not my fault
I think we can do it without Roger
I just ducked that [ __ ]
foreign
not worth that at all I'm gonna stop
doing that now
foreign
dude
this guy
this [ __ ] guy man
[ __ ]
input reading [ __ ]
finally Jesus
foreign
like 10 bucks ago
that reached me bruh
not fair
so fast oh
foreign
maybe I didn't have stamina there we go
foreign
man I suck
Morgan taught me many lessons I think
doing this on level six
what do we I think level six
and
uh as a wretch with a bonk stick
not the easiest way to do this
however
you guys know me right
you say go level up
go get two sticks
whatever
ask yourself do you think I'm gonna go
do that
or do you think I'm gonna keep doing
this until I get them
like come on
Mr delay
foreign
I was gonna say that first hit didn't
hurt too much and then he hit me three
more times
no do the jump
don't jump
I
despise you sir
I don't have any talismans
nah he's he's pimping out right now yep
kind of an early stage too huh
foreign
s that'll help me in this fight is what
I mean I have a pouch yes
I don't know if I've ever seen that
attack before in that way
that was weird
this [ __ ] guy dude holy [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy man
he just goes so ape [ __ ] at the end
this [ __ ] guy dude
looked like a more God attack okay
I bet
I [ __ ] rolled
so I don't have to hold down RT to do
the whole one two three I just have to I
have to touch it one time and you'll do
one two three
interesting
oh I didn't recognize it either
have you tried turning on gamer mode
not yet
I thought you had to hold down that
attack to do the three thing
learn something new every day
he holds his attack for an hour and then
just whips out
the little blade and goes as hard as he
can
foreign
does that do more or less damage
I don't know
God
that seems new to me but okay
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I hate this
not gonna happen is it you know what I
won't give him the satisfaction
[ __ ] you
it wasn't gonna happen that time guys
now I gotta work on my water look at
this thing
I haven't touched it yet today I gotta
drink all that today
I gotta work on it
drink all that by the end of the day
hydrate or die
yep
it's a pants issue a skill issue you're
right it is let's go back to this
I think we are having more success with
Roger
he takes a few more hits
that's okay
get that [ __ ] out of the way
foreign
just don't get hit that's the best
advice I've ever heard
you should write a book
on self-help advice
in gaming
foreign
get up in there my guy
he staggered me
this is gonna wear out
I feel a stagger yep
yep
rip
okay
this is doable
very doable
foreign
[Music]
and then get hit
I'm rolling
oh my God no
I don't think I've ever made that noise
in my life
can you stagger please
bruh
God
this is insanely difficult
hit the attack button roll when he
swings
how about Roger doesn't die in five
seconds and we get the dub
foreign
honestly we had it first try if I didn't
fall off the map
we really did
foreign
[Music]
why is my character not rolling
sometimes I'm getting concerned about it
at this point it's a lot of times now
foreign
oh wait I do have the dogs
good point
we got to get a bunch of joys in this
fight
this [ __ ]
whipped his ass around
did a full 180 10 split
just to hit me
[ __ ]
you got Reckless so did your mom
last night
you're gonna have a little brother or
sister in about nine months
I'm bringing the Wolves Out
and I forgot Roger
I forgot Roger damn it
this not a good start
you know what I have an idea
I have an idea
I have an idea
get Roger
for one unleash the dogs
can I Parry
no this doesn't Parry never mind
my idea is out the window
okay Roger
Wolfie boys
come on out
let's go
no greed
oh this is just nice
foreign
not fair
do the dogs stack anything besides just
damage like physical damage
I jumped over his tail I feel like a
beast
get him get him get him get him
just damage
cuteness gotcha
I think two of our dogs just died one of
them died
let's go Roger
foreign
[Music]
rip Roger all right
don't get greedy bait out the attacks
you want like this
win
dub it up baby dub it up
risk risk
okay
throw your darts at me my guy
do it
you're not gonna do it are you you're
gonna Corner me and then [ __ ] me
go
one more
nice
murdering with dimigo flag
power in fear of the night
the hand dubbed up Bell Omen shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
you suck
testing you to see whether or not Grace
truly does guide you and
whether you feel like I should stop
eating the apples
what does a crimson flask taste like
a Red Bull
you pretend there is but one other thing
I can do to offer you get Chipotle not
McDonald's
I think she's 30 minutes behind
by grace
honestly this girl isn't that hot
you guys think melon is hot
yes or no
I think she's cute
I think she's cute
but hot I don't know about that
she also doesn't exist so what are we
talking about
not a real person
hmm
I'm a guy shake my head oh sorry
Moana doesn't exist what do you mean
she's not real
he's a figment of your mind
okay should I finally
go get the big Club
where's that
imagine a tarnish joins the round table
for the first time and this is what
Gideon sees some naked guy with the club
dancing around on his table
you said it was behind the forlorn right
the
not that guy wait
this guy
near here
the actor of melano exists they look
exactly the same actually
wait what does she look like
I'm curious
now I'm actually curious
oh come on bro
what is this black ass box
[Music]
hello
thanks for the intro
to the thingy
all right
white screen
Melina wait Melina voice actor
[Music]
Alden ring
Marth meet martha Macintosh
dude
I hate the internet I'm sorry I hate it
let's go to images
there you go guys
is Martha hot
yes
I think she's cute
Martha's mid okay we gotta stop stop
dude
stop
did you guys know this is Melina or
Melania
that's Melania
Melanie is hot
but I think Melina is cute
good looking everyone's good looking
she's yorska
Melina
Melania dude I said Melania
blade of mcquella
yeah everybody's good looking
obviously
you know who's pretty cute
you guys
pretty good looking in the chat not
gonna lie
okay so where is this club at
I actually don't know
I have not used it you said it was
behind here somewhere
the shucks
I don't know what any of you look like
but I bet you're good looking
that's all
keep going down all right
is it in the cave
the cave
is it in there
it's a purple item on the floor
not a cave
shut up nerd idiot
Joy's barking
he's annoyed with something
your side of the water I don't know what
that means must be over here
[ __ ]
yeah isn't doing smash or pass like not
uh socially acceptable anymore or
something I don't remember
foreign
Club
that's what you guys are talking about
it do do more damn oh yeah that's a big
hammer
I like it
that's a big Bonk
the big Bonks
are here
should we also just stay like almost
naked the entire time
foreign
we're definitely not making the uh
our playthrough very easy
we got to go do other stuff
what can we do where can we go what can
we do where can we go what can we do
where can we go
I think we can beat this guy
okay
naked Unga Bunga
oh
I disconnected from chat are we back
okay what happened
it said chat disconnected please wait
while we try to reconnect you okay we're
back
go hit up godric dude that sounds
actually possible I think godric is
easier than Market
to be honest
when is DLC
I'm playing it right now
duh
the DLC is called big bunk
hello what is happening
oh I should probably two-hand it
oh okay
wait should I do this
I need 22 strength
Unga Bunga
I love it
okay I can two-hand it though right
we gotta get our strength up
[ __ ]
what level you capping at what do you
guys think
[Music]
what what is like the I think the level
the lowest level I want to go for for
DLC
would be I can pretty much I can beat
Melania but it's not easy what do you
think
because I I was gonna say like maybe we
stop at morgot like after morgot
I think that would make the most sense
but that's not even close to beating
Melania
because technically like they're
optional
I'd say in between there like maybe 80 I
think level 80 85 something like that
because I beat Melania at 80. and I it
took me like six hours
which was a lot uh so maybe like 85.90
just a hundred straight
we'll see where we get to
302
these blocks are unnecessary
why never mind
depends on weapon
I kind of want to use this weapon you
think we can beat the game like this
it's definitely possible
if we just level properly
God damn
this Bonk is beautiful
bomb
this is excellent
I'm having a good time with my big Bonk
stick
that's what she said okay
dude my character's body is goals
maybe a little lacking in the Bulge area
but everywhere else
great bod
great bod
IES
mimics here was hardest for you is it
because you were so powerful
I always use gigachat as a character
it's just cold you're right good point
nobody tell
who you know I'm I'm talking about right
now but I'm purposely ignoring him
[Music]
where are you right now to the South
weeping peninsula
rat
I don't hate you
I don't hate anybody
what are you talking about
that do be working Luke
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
I probably want to restart then Luke
this man can't even get a hit in
bunk
y bro
they can't even move
this is a this is actually a fun
character
actually fun
you've never fought that guy he's down
here Trey all the way to the South
yep
let's go attack good [ __ ] all right
where should we go now I guess God
Ric is not that hard
I think so bapo I I'm having a good time
with the Bonks
yeah I bet this build will get extremely
difficult later but we're gonna figure
it out
I'll get every item in the game that
makes
character stagger from my box
I really wanted the sword the guy drops
to be cool unfortunately it is not the
grafted blade yeah it looks cool
yes I will keep upgrading my Bonk
yeah I gotta go pee real quick
um talk to our boy here I'll be right
back
foreign
what
what's wrong chat
why are you arguing
not arguing
what's happening
get the giant Crusher
okay I'll have to find it
I'm thinking like 85 to 90.
jar
I think I'll stop once I get to that or
at least stop leveling
thumbs back whoa chat what's wrong like
what
are you talking about
you guys were talking about like baiting
DLC or something which is like
I mean did you read the title or did you
just get confused
fossil Hammer is too big perfect
okay
okay maybe I was wrong I I looked at
chat and it looked like people were
arguing
oh I wouldn't call the title bait either
I'm getting my character ready for DLC
okay why can't I jump up here sir sir
I'm dead
okay
bad
oh [ __ ]
Nah if you think this title is baby then
you're
thinking a little bit too much there
dicks debunk power
those 60 strength got it
you started New Game Plus to get ready
for DLC
I mean if that's if you want a new game
plus experience then go for it
yeah if you think the title's baby then
you're like looking for bait to be
honest
the entire Elden ring Community
overthinks everything
I'm not gonna disagree with you
what's the armor
uh nothing
okay
there is no armor
there never was all right
double great stars are available
[Music]
um great Club from oldest
for the big Bonk
I mean this is a pretty big buck right
now but we can always upgrade our bunks
Ellen ring brought in a bunch of dummies
um I don't know calling like titles or
thumbnails baby
oh really
even though I don't think the title is
either one of those things
for the thumbnail I think people like
just get mad about [ __ ]
on YouTube nowadays like if anything's
like that they just get mad even though
like everybody [ __ ] does it
you know I could the I think a baby
title would be Elden DLC come watch you
know what I mean
foreign
just weird
DLC draws people yeah but
is that all you're looking at
okay
the Box can handle this
maybe not yet
did I miss hello
God these are just the [ __ ] worst
enemies in the game bro
my God
I don't know what you just said Angel
anyone know what's the deal with the pod
looking things dead bodies in a remix of
God ones
the Pod looking things the dead bodies
are in a room next to Godwin's body
downstairs
what
uh urge tree Avatar weapons that could
be great Bonk sticks for later and the
trolls Club could be good too you mean
the avatar
they're I forget what I think it's a
staff right
Avatar staff
nah that doesn't feel like a bonk
okay
I like it Luke
can you just ban that guy Stan he's
being weird
no don't ban him just keep timing him
out until he stops
all right let's get it
I'll try no nephelia if I need her then
I'll go get her
I feel like a band's too much
true born air
lend me thy strength I would like to say
when I woke up and saw the stream posted
I thought sweet a new stream while he
waits for DLC that's exactly that's the
whole point I'm not trying to bait
anybody
it's like people
they think the worst thing like the
worst intentions right away which makes
no sense to me like
I don't know maybe if I've been doing
that for forever then like yeah but
I'm clearly not doing that
is golden I mean yeah should my title
just be live playing Elden ring
super interesting
all right I gotta get used to the big
stick
foreign
holy [ __ ] okay yeah I have
I could swing like one time I think
what's your average viewer's age oh like
20 to 35.
it's not kids
I have like almost no kids in my uh
in my audience based on what YouTube
tells me
I can see where people get upset
I don't but okay
oh it actually is a big St like it's the
same thing that's awesome
oh my God
[ __ ]
whoa
hey he's gonna kill me in one hit
yeah my stamina is just not looking good
guys
run
foreign
foreign
where's the transition
find the four Lauren evergale
where the sponk stick is no
foreign
excellent
foreign
getting used to it
nice
that's almost not fair
hmm
close one
let's go
the [ __ ]
the Box stick
beautiful
foreign
God gamer
uh okay
the Bonk Lord should we change our name
to the Bonk Lord
I don't know why but it's so much more
satisfying watching someone play
strength build than playing it yeah
strength build is actually kind of hard
literally is
uh but
it's satisfying to play
I'm sure this this build will be very
difficult later
we get that 22 20.
good have enough to upgrade
go back
Boomer is just an insult now used by
kids uh it's really meant for like 70
and up yeah it's a joke like when you
know people call me a boomer and I'm 27.
like
obviously I'm not a boomer but
it it's just a joke
you are the Lord of all that is punk
yes I have the soul of a boomer
I will never be sad of this
yep
okay what else can I do
um I feel like ranala would be
pretty easy
no cap
we want to have the ultimate box stick
that is the goal of this build
they talk so much here
little tragic across the farm but the
grace of Grace
I think that's possible jump scare
if I keep talking to her don't I get a
pouch oop not what I want to do
can I get a pouch from here this early
or do I have to
have to wait
it's not like I have any talismans
anyway
it's after Ronaldo okay
you think that's where we should go now
oh I'll have to beat the the doggy
before Ronaldo
I think that's possible
think
Ronaldo hates Bonks you really do
I'm like using almost nothing but the
those won't do anything for me where's
the um
is there a Talisman that'll just make my
box stronger
stronger stronger
the stamina Talisman should be good too
we could go get that that's actually the
direction we should be going good point
let me go get that
there's the jump attack one
yeah
we should be going uh
this way I think
star Scourge claw talisman
is this considered
isn't there a hammer talisman
is this I mean it's a pretty [ __ ] big
hammer
or is that in ax
I remember
it's a hammer talisman
okay
yeah I do watch bushy I like his videos
his challenge runs are very entertaining
to watch
we're arguing about Mayo what
I like Mayo
oh [ __ ] I just break this nope
they hurt each other let's go
when is DLC coming out I have no idea
I'm just getting ready for it I didn't
have any characters ready for a DLC
release
they're all either too strong or
on New Game Plus
10 or whatever
Mayo's disgusting dude Mayo's good what
are you talking about bro
that's crazy
why did I grab that why did I do that
okay
because that's what happens there
yep
foreign
we are making a bonk character big
strength
big Bonks
yeah it's great to like kind of spread
on the underside of bread on a sandwich
Mayo's bong like really good
torrent needs his own upgrades dude I'm
surprised that hasn't been an update as
well
I literally can't move okay
because that would be easy
okay bro
it's not bad for these guys
no I don't put mayo on a spoon and eat
it
that's that's kind of gross
I put it on sandwiches on the other side
of saying underside of sandwiches
I think that's like what they're meant
for right
this guy's selling anything of use
oh Daryl terribly sorry
um I mean you have those I can get those
later if need be okay
you've never had McDonald's
um I'd go ahead and keep it that way I'm
not gonna lie go ahead and keep it that
way
it is some stuff oh yeah McDonald's is
pretty good
a lot of shit's not good
but some things I think are good
I like getting a Double Quarter Pounder
I think they're like McDonald's fries
are extremely good
very good
um
there don't get anything chicken related
I think they're McDonald's breakfast is
super good like a mick like a mcbiscuit
a McMuffin
those are really good
I think a McGriddle pretty good as well
big Bonk kills ghost
dagger
that's what I like to see
you don't have McDonald's in your
country there's probably a reason for
that
thank you
why aren't these skeletons just doing
nothing okay
okay
um it's over here right yeah
cereal plus mayo and salt
what
gross
yeah chat don't turn into Twitter
is an awful place
opinions
just be nice about it Twitter's not nice
about it
use Mayo instead of butter next time on
your grilled cheese I mean I I would put
it on the underside but I would use
butter
you know
you like Twitter I deleted Twitter I no
longer have a Twitter and I haven't for
two months now and my life has been
exponentially better since I deleted it
I just [ __ ] hate it
as a Creator it's trash
awful
I think for the normal you know user of
Twitter it's pretty nice
it's okay
but as a Creator nope
[Laughter]
oh my God Anastasia
the Box hmm
what does this do
raises holy attack nah
all right I might give it a try Javin I
don't really eat grilled cheese that
much
I will make like 150 on Elon buying
Twitter
why what are you invested in
or is it like a bet
would you be mad if we burnt people in
your chat alive yes that sounds like
murder
don't murder people in the chat please
thank you
I'd appreciate it if you didn't kill
each other
thanks guys I didn't think I'd ever have
to say that
is DLC confirmed nope I'm just hoping
there is and I'm getting a character
ready
did somebody say grilled cheese
uh we are talking about grilled cheese
Andrew the grilled cheese is back my man
and thank you for the two dollars I
appreciate it
you've got those emotes you guys don't
use them
you are all about the emotes of the
grilled cheese
and nobody uses it you goofballs
hey you're already here I didn't think
you'd be here
if it isn't a tarnished wire
oh we can't go this way right now can we
oh that's not open from this side
there you go
there you go
you must be whack
all right I have a question for you guys
we don't have very many members in the
channel and I would like to change that
what would be a good enough reason for
you to become a member
it's three dollars for the lowest tier
I'll just ask straight up what do you
think it would be worth it to you to
become a member
because I wouldn't like more
I would like more
are you asking for money I'm not asking
for money I just want more members in
the channel
you get more emotes I can see your chat
message better
I don't know be a part of the community
what do you want to do
see that's such a Twitter reply
such a Twitter thing
I'll see I mentioned it two of you
become a member huh laughs
let's go
master and d Meyer I appreciate it guys
welcome
to the community it's good to have you
here
priority chats I see your messages
easier when you remember that is very
true
so thank you D thank you master welcome
to the tarnish good to have you here
members only chat huh
no I'd never do that
thank you again Andrew I appreciate it
didn't know twitch had Subs they do
they do we have different tiers there's
like three dollars five dollars uh
20 you can go all the way up to 100
bucks I only have one member that's an
outer God and it's bones
yeah members only chat isn't the right
way to go about it
see Angel became a great room that's the
five dollar one
all
well witness I'm not gonna give you guys
feet picks I'm not gonna do it
angel thank you for becoming thank you
for becoming a great ruin welcome to the
community enjoy the emotes
that you can spam when I die or
something dumb happens
that's kind of fun I I do think there
should be more of an incentive to do so
right
where do I get a membership it should be
um bottom left corner of the chat for
you or you can go to the description
it'll give you a link to it
you'll say become a member
garnishes one dollar it should be three
if it was one dollar
that's interesting
next to the Subscribe button should say
join wrecked
correct amundo
I'm not giving you guys feet picks it's
not gonna happen
I don't see the join are you on mobile
[Music]
jeez guys
wolf thank you for becoming a great Rune
as well I appreciate it thank you
I've been enjoying your content for a
while now see that's the main thing like
if I make good content and you guys want
to support
then you can become a member that's a
great way to support
it's 50 off to become a member right now
are you dead ass really
actually didn't know this
hold on I have to go on here
member membership
hey it says three bucks for me
yeah it says three bucks
I'm not embarrassed of my feet I just
don't want you guys to have it
okay hey if there's a sale on Subs right
or members right now go for it boys if
you want to
all I'm asking besides feet picks
besides feet picks what do you guys want
like I'm asking the members now now that
you are becoming members and I
appreciate it thank you what do you guys
want to keep becoming a member like what
do you think would make more members or
people want to become more members
not giving you guys a pinky toe
picks of the feet
what can you offer I don't know
um
[Music]
let's go Spartan
maybe I just gotta talk about it
I maybe a lot of you guys don't even
know it exists
interesting
um
[Music]
thank you guys
that's all it took I guess huh I just
had to bring it up now we've gotten like
10.
it is relatively new for YouTube
wolf Spartan Slayer and Martin and
statsny
thank you for becoming members
I appreciate it I want to do something
quote though
hmm
you guys are going nuts holy [ __ ]
a Shameless self-promotion
yeah
I think that's why Luke oh God that's me
bro to be honest you make good content
advertise some
well I want to give you guys something
you know
a special member stream
hmm Andrew thank you for the two
bappo became a great room thank you bro
and master with the two bucks another
one he says thank you
appreciate it
so thank you guys
um
should we make a members only Discord
it could be interesting
what would you guys do in there
just be weird
is there a way to do member only things
on YouTube yes
um there are member chats
there are membership
uh like you know you guys know the
community tab on YouTube there's a
member only version of that but I don't
we haven't had enough members from even
think of doing that right
you guys would be really weird you'd
send pictures of your feet and grilled
cheese excellent
excellent dude
regular Discord with several member
rooms including dog picks four fathers I
like this idea
because I already have a Discord
people don't talk in it very much but we
could have a member only part of that
Discord or we can just make a new
Discord with only members
John Michael Barnett thank you as well
man I appreciate
the membership welcome to the tarnished
good to have you here man thank you
at this rate we can start a feet cult
beautiful
the quality is there I wish it was
easier for you to expand into different
games as far as lore breakdowns but I
understand YouTube doesn't always like
that
it really doesn't man that's I
appreciate you bringing that up Javin
because
there's a reason I haven't been making
videos
it's because I'm I'm just not as
interested in the lore of eldering right
now that I was when the game came out
I'm just not
I want to be
yeah I have a regular Discord if you
guys go into the description you can see
everything that I got
you should join it I I will definitely
make a members only version of that
Discord not a version but a channel and
a few channels there too I think that's
the best idea I have right now but if I
think of anything else
like maybe we do like PVP events and
only members can join or something that
would kind of make sense just to kind of
like
I don't know weed out weird people who
are trolling or whatever
make it so I can send memberships I
can't just change the rules man
of how mobile works
that's what my uh that's what my
community is called is the agency yeah
agent Jake
the algorithm [ __ ] with creators it
absolutely does I'm having a ton of fun
streaming
lately
um
here's the thing though that I want to
talk about real quick and thank you guys
for becoming members and in the super
chats I really appreciate it it supports
me a lot it supports me much more than
you think
because the fact is I'm not making
videos right now which means I'm getting
less views which means we don't get as
many Subs which means blah blah blah all
the algorithm [ __ ] right
I'm gonna take the risk of going into
other games
because I have to
hello why literally have to
one like the reason I have to is because
that's just how I am I don't play one
game forever and enjoy it I play lots of
different games I'm playing OverWatch
too a lot right now
um I was playing Apex Legends with my
friends all the time I've been playing
all the other Souls games
you know
stuff like that
I have to take risks otherwise I'm gonna
stagnate in the Elder ring Community
they don't make enough content for us to
like
they don't have enough updates for us to
make content about all the time without
it becoming stale and bad like just
straight up bad content
right
so
I'm gonna I'm going to start taking
those risks I'm going to
mainly because I have to and because I
want to keep making content but I'm
gonna do that for games that aren't like
OverWatch or Apex and stuff because
those have those their communities
what I would like to do
is um you guys know the game scorn
coming out on Friday we're gonna play
that we'll make a few videos on it
however like video like whatever videos
that we come out of that with I'm gonna
stream it we're gonna play it
and I that's what I'd like to do is like
new games that are coming out we play
those we play the new games without
completely dismissing the souls
Community you know like when Eldon ring
DLC comes out or a new game comes out
we're gonna be on that [ __ ] right away
you know
or new Souls like gamespocky exactly
stuff like that
um
because over the last couple months I've
made like what two videos or something
yeah
scoring is hyped up we're gonna play
lives of lives of P absolutely
so I'm gonna take those risks but it's
gonna make sense you know what I mean
like I I don't think any of you guys
would be interested in me playing
OverWatch too I just don't there's tons
of streamers out there who are playing
OverWatch too it's kind of a multiplayer
Twitchy type of thing whereas like scorn
comes out that's a new cam like new
story thing that we can play
um there's uh God of War coming out
we're absolutely going to play God of
War Ragnarok on here just to like get it
lives of Lies a p scoring like all that
stuff we're gonna lay the [ __ ] games
that are coming out
the fact of the matter is the last
couple months
games haven't been coming out
you know what I mean there hasn't been
many games
be honest
bizarre thank you don't worry I'll
support you no matter what I appreciate
that dude thank you for the five dollar
Super Chat that's a very nice of you
you know and I like I understand
that people subscribe to this channel
for the lore
they did and I think I did that
I put out my videos that I was
interested in that I was enjoying and I
put those out there I don't want to make
a lore video on just some random
character in the game that you guys
already know about
it won't provide any unique content to
it
you know
no Skyrim came out 15 years ago or
however long long time ago it's been
played to death I appreciate the two
dollar Super Chat too man thank you
here's the other thing about this
and you got press one in the chat if you
agree with me
hold on
Billy thank you man thank you for the
two months of being a tarnish I
appreciate you
I lured my ass off Joey I really did but
am I just gonna make content about
everything no and here's why
guys press one if you agree with me
Smoketown and vati video got this [ __ ]
they got you they're doing it
Smoketown makes the best lore videos
I've ever seen they're an hour and a
half long filled with amazing content
filled with all the information you
could ever want
they got it they're doing it
vati Vidya is making cinematic
masterpieces with the [ __ ] team of
people
a whole team of paid employees to help
him make these cinematic masterpieces
those were the two ideas I had one make
lore videos smokes got it he's got all
the information you could ever want all
of it
and two I wanted to make cinematic lore
videos
there is absolutely no way I could
compete with vazi video on that it's
just not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen and I don't have
to like try and do that just just don't
see makes me all dewy what does that
mean
silly thank you again and Angel
I was one lore subscriber but then I
stayed that's what I want
like
I think that's how you grow a community
it means moist oh
oh morning dew
gotcha gotcha can't agree because I
don't know either of those people I
highly recommend it please go watch them
Smoketown is killing it he has
he has probably the greatest work ethic
I've ever seen
the dude puts out an hour and a half
long video on very certain things about
uh lore aspects of the game every week
to two weeks
that is unbelievable that he can write
all that record it all put it out there
he's got it he's got your back if you
guys want that please watch him
because he's got it when it comes to the
Cinematic stuff vati videos got it he is
clearly the goat
but I don't think I like I think my
videos were very very good
but are they at those levels no they're
just not and that's fine
that's totally fine
also to to talk about that a little bit
I'm not like that
that's not me
is I'm kind of a goofball that likes
these games a lot
and I like talking with my chat if like
that's why I called my videos lore
hunting for the most part because I
didn't pretend to know everything I
mostly asked you guys what you thought
you know what I mean and I'm not seeing
anyone else is pretending to know know
things
but
I don't want to fake like I'm doing that
because honestly if I were to keep doing
lore [ __ ] like that
I
it's just too confusing to me
there are two people out there that
completely understand it they have
incredible communities that are
constantly asking questions and going
over the lore of the game they got it
so I don't really feel like I'm making
an impact in those areas
you know
I don't feel like I'm making a solid
positive impact in my lore videos
oh and yes zolly the witch if you guys
want way out there stuff that you would
never even think about ever think about
go watch Zoe the witch
incredible she literally hacks the game
so that she can find these underlying
messages that are put throughout the
game absolutely incredible of course of
course
it's amazing
so
that's the main thing is I like making
content where I feel like I'm making an
impact in a difference on the community
or with my community and if you guys
have watched me I'm kind of a [ __ ]
goofball I like just talking to my
community about stuff
and we play games
that's all I've ever wanted to do and do
I want that to be one game of course not
there's so many other games out there
that we could experience
and a lot of you guys don't know this
I've gone viral in three different games
Elden ring was the latest one so it was
I got 20 000 Subs
22 000 Subs
on another Channel that I [ __ ]
deleted
on valorant
I played Omen valorant when it came out
we went absolutely viral like 20 000
Subs in a week or something
and then viral like I didn't want to
play Valiant anymore and every time I
tried to post new content the channel
would just never get any views and that
demoralized me and then
um I had stopped posting and eventually
deleted the channel and started a new
one
if you look at my my first videos on
this channel it's a rocket League
we got 230
000 followers on Tick Tock doing rocket
League tip tips and tricks
um
and then we had I think I averaged
around a thousand viewers on Twitch with
rocket league for the course of about
six months
just doing coaching and playing rocket
league and stuff and then guess what I
didn't want to play the game anymore I
was over it and I wanted to play
something else but I built my entire
community
off of one game
which is a mistake eventually I know
myself I'm going to get bored and I'm
going to do something else
so
what I'm doing is I'm slowly
incorporating other games
like what I've been doing over the past
couple weeks right I
played Securo I played bloodborne I
played Dark Souls 1. we did an Elden
ring randomizer we're doing Elden ring
again so we're slowly incorporating it
to where it's not like I'm randomly
posting rocket League content you know
what I'm saying
I'm sorry I'm going off on a tangent
right now because I really wanted to
talk to you guys about this
this seemed like a good point too
this is only the witch Smoketown vati
and tarnish archaeologists are the Lord
Lords but Jake is like your gaming bro
that's exactly how I want it to be
I want to be the guy that you go to when
you're interested in a game and you want
to like chill with me for a while while
I play it
so
I'm not going to
because I'll tell you guys I have
I have
so many videos ready
written out completely ready to go
for lore for lore [ __ ] and as I'm making
them I'm
I feel like I'm not gonna make an impact
with it so I don't I'm just not going to
continue to make it to post it
because that's that's all I want to do
is make content that I feel like is an
impact on the people who watch it
it's not gonna be like I'm throwing [ __ ]
out there because I am sorry there are
so many [ __ ] creators out there that
just throw [ __ ] out there
all over the place to just like
it's just not good
I'm not gonna release them they're not
good enough killer
and you know why I thought that because
of all of these other incredible content
creators who are doing that job better
than me
so I'm not going to release a video
on the golden order
because guess what or uh Smoketown
killed it absolutely killed it didn't
kill my video but he went over
everything that I did and I just you
know
I didn't want to just stack on top of
that
because he he killed it
it was I watched it I'm like this is
perfect I don't need to put my video out
there
which might be weird
um where I
you know
it's hard to put
like I was saying it's not gonna make a
big enough impact my video compared to
his so I'm just not gonna release it
that's it
that's fine
what games would you like to play base
your YouTube channel around uh games
that are coming out like scorn is coming
out on Friday
um we've got the Modern Warfare 2
campaign we got God of War Ragnarok
coming out I have a list on a whiteboard
right here we can play little nightmares
one and two just for like a Halloweeny
thing
Joy's barking
yeah but that's what I'm gonna do sorry
I'm I'm going on like a [ __ ] tangent
now
not a tangent but I've just been
thinking about this for two months and
there's a reason why I haven't been um
posting videos
and I've just been streaming
uh I'd go back like
10 minutes Jose if you want the the gist
of it
I've never played Hollow Knight another
game I haven't played is outer Wilds
I've heard so many good things about
outer Wilds that I think I want to try
that out
um I understand that you don't want to
become like a Skyrim content creator
like honey for little tidbits of lore 10
years later better to cover a game for a
while and move on can always come back
that's exactly what I'm saying wolf
exactly I can always come back
to a game
Alden ring DLC comes out Elden Ring 2
comes out bloodborne 2 comes out we're
on that [ __ ] we're playing it absolutely
but when a new exciting game comes out
like scoring on Friday or God of War
Ragnarok I want to be able to do that I
want to be able to sit down Starfield I
want to try absolutely
um Starfield doesn't look that good but
let's [ __ ] play it dude why not we
can talk about how bad it is if it's bad
or how good it is how good it is if it's
good
so I want to be the Creator
that I know I can be we've gone viral in
several different games
so
I know it's possible
for me to do it I just gotta do it I
gotta take those risks because like
someone said earlier making new content
on video games that the people who
subbed here aren't used to is a major
major risk but you gotta you gotta grind
through that to get to the light at the
end of that tunnel
because it is very possible people do it
there's lots of content creators out
there that play tons of different games
uh and they
that's how Their audience works we can
absolutely do that and that's what I'm
gonna go for
I think I'll try haul tonight too I just
I think I have it on my Xbox
pretty sure I do
it was like a free game and I just
downloaded it but I haven't played it
you can be a Creator who puts pants on
their characters sure
it's good to let out the steam
I wouldn't I'm not angry about anything
there's no steam here I just like
I like talking to you guys about this
stuff
because who else am I going to talk to
it about
nobody else really understands like
what's what I'm doing
I haven't played fall and order before
Jedi fall in order never played it
that's one problem with lore for games
because with how many lore content
creators there are on games it's hard
for others to make vids on stuff when
it's already been covered very well by
others that's that's the the thing bappo
is
let's say Smoketown in vazi Vidya didn't
exist
or they didn't make content
it I would feel like I am for my videos
I feel like I would be providing value
to the community
making my videos
if they didn't if they weren't there and
I'm not like saying that uh
this is the fault of either of them that
I'm not making content it's just how it
is
they are absolutely killing it
and
like I was saying I'm not feeling that
that role that would make me happy
which for the first four months of the
game out
every video I put out I felt like
offered that offered the
um
value
no I'm not planning to assassinate them
I love their videos I want to see
everything they make
so it's not like that at all
I only want the success of both of those
people
like
I know I don't have that hour and a half
long video like that's just not how I am
I can't sit and talk for an hour and a
half about
one piece of lore like smoke town can I
don't have the team available for me to
make a cinematic TV show
of Eldon ring like vazi video does
they're both killing killing it at the
things that I would want to do in the
Elder ring community
but I don't feel the need to now because
they are just they're killing it so
I'm gonna move on to something where I
feel like I can that's all
you think vati edits all his videos and
does everything himself Josh
he I think he said multiple times that
he has a full team of people
you think the Reddit pushed back a few
months ago led to the frustration you
feel too diversifying is good too just
curious
I think so I think it did it made me a
bit uh
it made me very
aware of how the souls Community is
the souls Community is very
very judgmental
and
a little bit gatekeepy
and very uh I can't think of the words
that whole Reddit Fiasco that happened
months ago
what a horrible taste in my mouth and
every time I uploaded a video all I was
thinking to myself was I hope somebody
else didn't make a video about this
because if they did
I'm just gonna get [ __ ] harassed by
people who are like you're stealing
somebody else's content
and it's like dude I can't scour the
[ __ ] internet and see what everyone
said about everything I can't it's
impossible and for four months that's
all that happened every time I posted a
video
somebody would be in the comments
somebody would send me messages on
Twitter or Discord saying that I'm a
fraud and I stole content when I know I
didn't do that
people telling me who I am people
telling me that my character and like
that I'm a [ __ ] fraud like
I know myself I know I didn't do those
things but they're literally telling me
that I did
because
I made a video on a subject that
somebody already talked about it's
that made me very bitter I think is the
word
and I still made videos for a few months
after that but it definitely had
something to do with it for sure
a bit elitist I think so
little gatekeepy yeah
yeah it's uh
it's a tough Community that's for sure
it's not it's not Call of Duty
yeah
where we're playing Cod and everyone
wants the gun
uh Loadout or whatever you know
I don't know Josh I'm gonna shoot for
like level 85 to 90 for this character
not yet Travis so I'm just getting ready
for one
as uh
I believe Dark Souls 3 and bloodborne's
first DLC was announced in October when
they released in March February just
like Elven ring did
the souls Community is a great Community
they're [ __ ] awesome
but there's a lot of pit heads in every
community
I I know handgun it's it just doesn't
matter
uh I stream until I'm done Spartan I
don't really have a time frame
let's play Minecraft
I don't know if I want 10 year olds in
my chat
I think that'll always be a case where
if I if I feel like my age demographic
is getting a little young I think I'm
going the wrong way
all right I'll keep playing but yeah
sorry I went on a tangent man
I did definitely want to talk about that
it's been on my mind for months
months you have a ponytail
no
start cursing
sir can you please not can you not cuss
I've I had I had people uh do that
in when I was a rocket League streamer
there were people that would be like can
you please not cuss
dude I am not bad
at Minecraft I don't know where Stan is
getting that from
he's lying I'm amazing at Minecraft
it's a good chat it's a good chat
after playing through Elden ring six
times I jump back into sea of Thieves
how is it
RL streamers are usually seven do you
mean um
you mean viewers because yes
it's just bad I don't know what else to
say okay
okay buddy
your broccoli career is over
I'm fine with that my rocket League
career died before it began
Bonk
so
all of you guys would be okay with me
trying out other games that are not in
the souls
category
like new releases the my the one that I
want to play the most is scorn
it looks like a cool new game that's
coming out on
Friday
absolutely not okay
you all seemed very about it so okay
I'm gonna take that risk I'm gonna do it
just know that it's terrifying for me
it is terrifying
but we have to
only if you put on pants
what if I don't have any
literally don't have pants
I'm basically only buying games off your
recommendation
kind of like a review
play Among Us
dude that would be fun with viewers or
something
dude we could have like member game
nights
that'd be cool like if you're a member
then we can uh
play like among us some nights or
something on stream that would be fun or
just like off stream
maybe that could be what the discord's
for
let me show you guys scoring real quick
because I actually have not seen a
trailer I just heard it was coming out
and people are hyping it up
for sure
okay you two
tube
go up game nights that could be fun
hey it's me
uh okay Gorn
how is someone already played it
oh it was a that's right it was a demo
trailer 4K
it's not a shooter I don't believe
one month ago
okay you're gonna hear Eldon ring [ __ ]
in the background
I don't care
[Music]
because this game does look pretty cool
wulong's another game too that we could
try
this like art Direction looks really
cool to me
sick
thank you
I've heard skull and bones is kind of
poopy
[Music]
it just looks very interesting
foreign
s Legacy absolutely we will play
what the [ __ ]
foreign
a Grizzly nightmare of Macabre
perception
greetings
I'm your host the straight up Gameplay
trailer holy [ __ ] I invite you to join
me as we explore scorn's mesmerizing
Labyrinth of odd forms and somber
tapestries
War narrator you awake
the middle of a desert my chimpanzee
filled with biomechanical Contraptions
part flesh part machine
Civilization now lying in Decay and ruin
oh hidden fauna sleeps within the
underbelly of the world wanting nothing
more than to be left and undisturbed
yeah it looks like alien isolation
has been carefully crafted with great
attention to detail everything is
focused on building a specific
atmosphere
from a unique organic ecosystem to an
unsettling soundscape created by ethak
and lustmore yeah kind of Doom Vibes as
well scorn has no dialogue so most of
the storytelling comes from the
environment discovering no dialogue
biotic relationships and how things are
connected equips you with the tools to
progress okay while there is shooting
we're used to that game
is not a shooter
not a shooter encounter must be
carefully considered a wrong choice
could be
deadly wow
I hope you've been very creepy glimpse
into the Twisted world of scorn what is
that
the team at AB software can't wait for
you to uncover the secrets of this
unique world as you experience scorn
firsthand this October
puzzle Focus Bioshock pad to unravel
your inner self
within scorn's world of Horror
I think it looks very interesting he's
he's calmed down that looks very
interesting we're I'm definitely gonna
play that
so that's what we'll be doing on Friday
is we'll be playing that game it comes
out then
goofy narration I kind of liked it
it's okay all right
I lost my appetite
definitely looks like a game you don't
want to play while you're eating
absolutely
scorn puzzles are kind of like missed
game puzzles
I haven't played mist
I got my big Club
yeah that's what we'll be doing on
Friday
um
tomorrow
and Wednesday we're gonna play little
nightmares one and two guaranteed okay
that'll be our first glimpse into the
new games
little nightmares one and two
actually very excited for that
game looks dangerous
to try fingers butthole
I agree
I agree
fingers butthole very dangerous
you're feeling weirdly hungry now
that seems strange
how do I say your name
uh Subaru deep
thank you for becoming a tarnished I
appreciate it man enjoy the emotes enjoy
the badge next to your name
I appreciate it dude thank you welcome
three fighter Six coming down the pipe
I played a street fighter before I think
I'd just be trash at it let's call me
Shiro you got it
there was another game ARCA you guys
heard of
what's it called is it just called
Arkham Knights is there a new Arkham
game coming out that has to do with like
Batman or something
I'm about 10 a.m tomorrow as well Javin
gotta say shout out to Hal for the free
membership you can gift members as well
that is a thing
oh Gotham Knights that's what it's
called
Gotham Knights not Arkham Knights Arkham
Knight's already a thing
that looks pretty cool I'm a big fan of
Batman I don't think Batman's in the
game but I do like that DC world
we could try that
yes thank you
yeah you can gift members now that's
relatively new and sometimes doesn't
work
and you also can't do it on mobile I
believe so that's sad
this is why I miss most of your streams
because I'm usually at work this time
yeah I don't know whether to
um stream while people are at work or
after they're done with work
because a lot of people will tell me
like
that they really like watching me while
they work
and then I've heard some other takes on
that too
can't give specific memberships yeah
that does kind of suck
which is definitely way ahead on that
but YouTube it's such an easy fix that
they can they can get that done pretty
quick
you choose between four different
characters and your choice is important
do I fight you
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
dream of both times
I haven't tried that before
we could we could do like a three hour
stream during the day in a three hour
stream at night
that could be interesting I used to do
that on Twitch and it usually went
pretty well
yeah I don't know if I can Bonk this guy
let's actually not try
I think that's gonna be a no for me boys
on that one
foreign
you can watch videos but not always
right
very true
I would if I could but working on cars
six my attention might be changing
shifts soon still debating
I feel you
really I feel you
what level are you
24.
not very high level
yeah we got to get these things though
getting where they are
had some Sammy's
I'm getting kind of hungry too
wow it's almost 2 P.M
ow you [ __ ]
wouldn't even touch the underground
I'm only here to beat the deer because
the deer is very easy
runes
oh [ __ ]
perfect timing
because those guys will kill me
instantly
Caleb's the baby version of scored
yeah kinda
we'll see
you
where to go now
we go up here
yeah I still have not tried Neo I don't
think I want to
we'll see
it's not on my list right now but maybe
someday
dead rat not a dead rat not strong
enough to kill a rat
what build are you making a bonk build
big strength Vigor stamina Bonk build
oh God
rise of ronin thousand percent I saw the
trailer for that and it looks amazing
that looks great
ignore the giant arrows sticking out of
my
my arm
it's fun but hard way harder than
soulsborne games in my opinion but
similar
okay I might try it someday
give it a try
foreign
I didn't even see that rat
nope the DLC is not announced I'm just
getting ready for it
yeah I saw some gameplay of wulong and
that looked very interesting too
weapon type
what weapon type would you like to see
them add in the DLC
I don't know that's a good question
I don't think they will
besides boss weapons
I wonder what type of weapon mikola has
or queen America I wonder if they even
had any
yeah it seems like the range options are
pretty limited for the most part
all right let's see if we can beat this
deer this is probably gonna be pretty
close
despite usually pretty easy
let's see
yikes
pretty much if I get hit we die
foreign
I couldn't cancel out
there we go
foreign
just for the music
oh yep see there you go
yep
yep yep yep
foreign
weapons
there's not that many is there oh I got
some text I might be in trouble boys
we are not in trouble poggers in the
chat not in trouble
hello
hello
favorite boss theme
of any game
or Alden ring
uh yes I literally can't [ __ ] up you
know I'm dead this this thing hits hard
did not last long
oh she's an Elden ring probably this one
this one's one of my favorites uh
radagons is [ __ ] epic eldenbeast is
the only good thing about that fight is
the OST
um Renault is beautiful
um
I think those are mine I think so
might be forgetting something
Estelle's is cool
I will say after playing sakiro
the demon of hatred
is one of my favorite osts ever
yeah the godskin of course I forget
about the godskin yep obviously yep
godskins are awesome
godfreeze is good
foreign
the answer was no
what the
Never Had It follow me like that the
heck
sometimes you do too sometimes you do
three
bruh I kill this thing so fast every
time I fight it I don't know the I don't
even know
the movements
oh I don't even have healing this is not
good
come on big Bonk you can do it
why
I should have died but we did not
we take those
no
I didn't have stamina
I had no stamina
I want the option for full-time
companion that follows around everywhere
you can upgrade them and give them gear
that'd be interesting
you mean like Fallout
I died
what is your favorite entity in the game
Enemy character whatever favorite like
thing in the entire game
that's a really good question
I think the thing that interests me the
most
is obviously the broader thing which is
the family Dynamic of all the demigods
and queen America
I find that to be the most interesting
art of the whole game
is
I wonder like I I just want to know
before the shattering like what their
real relationships were
I find the whole family to be very
interesting
very very interesting
yeah I got it this time 100 percent
zero deaths
that [ __ ] tracks you
yeah I have like no no no no
all the bad things I did chat
foreign
thought I had time
this this weapon
just annihilates
my stamina bar
I jump once attack and then I can't roll
for like three seconds
yeah this stream is not gonna age well
on the channel if the game never gets
DLC can you imagine
foreign
just get more stamina
dude true
good point
[Music]
I want those roots
foreign
let me roll out man
bro you're confusing
this boss is hard when you're under
leveled
makes me wonder if I should have been
here
yeah we got lucky
holy [ __ ]
oh and I gotta step it up bro this is
trash
foreign
[Music]
what
I thought he was doing a back kick
foreign
but here we are
thank you
goodness
there we go
Bonk boy wins
how many runes do I get for that 13k is
pretty good I think that's worth
for sure for sure
Pro Gamer the Bonk worked
zero deaths I didn't even die
we don't die here
we only succeed
it's the only way
okay
now
we have found the underground
we need to go
wait we beat godric right
yeah we did
I don't even remember beating godric I
feel like that was two hours ago holy
[ __ ] I've been streaming for four hours
wow
time flies when you're having fun
I should go get uh his great room
this is really good early game
um okay so I have three levels
one more into that I'm putting some into
endurance man we need it
explore Caleb and come out like a chad
I mean I should probably look up where
certain talismans are things like that
but you know
how was that an hour and 15 minutes ago
I don't know dude
maybe it was like the hour long
rant I went on
do you work out five times a week
I have two rest days
I have two days of the week where I
don't eat either
I fast
on Wednesdays and Sundays
I've been doing that for a while which
has helped me lose
almost 40 pounds now
my roll didn't work
or I rolled too slow
make it eight
I should
drugs or alcohol
um I might have like a cocktail
like vodka tonic
I don't really drink that much at all
maybe a couple times a week if that
the fasting it was the hardest part
where I literally don't eat for 24 hours
but the
what made it easier
was I have dinner the night before my
fasting day so I have
um
I eat it about 6 p.m because I also
think that you shouldn't eat full meals
like right before you go to bed
so about three to four hours before I go
to bed and then I sleep through most of
it and then I get to eat again at around
6 pm
so
yeah
the 24 hours goes a lot faster where you
sleep through most of it at the
beginning
but around 3 P.M on every fasting day
I'm like
but apparently it's really good for you
I already do something about losing
weight I've lost around because I was
too my heaviest I was 225 pounds
and now I weigh 185. so that's 40 pounds
pretty close to it right now I'm
lingering like I don't lose weight as
fast as I did before
um
I'm lingering between 185 and 190.
I need to lift heavier weights for
longer if I want to lose more weight
well I don't really want to lose more
weight
I could gain weight
now at this point
if I really wanted to lose more weight
on what I'm at I'd have to do more
cardio and I [ __ ] hate running
um
but some like I'll put the uh the
treadmill on an incline and I'll walk
for about half an hour that's been
really good you can lose weight so
[ __ ] fast doing that
yeah I'm almost I oh I'm almost at a
point where I can bulk back up Trey like
maybe gain a bit of weight but I'm not
quite there yet
I need to lose a bit more
yeah treadmill incline is a literal
cheat code it actually is if you have a
lot of like fat to lose it just burns
off you
I don't count calories at all Bucky I
just don't eat that much food
I think that's the key when it comes to
diet is you just don't eat don't eat as
much as you think you should and then
this
this is a cheat code too and I'm doing
really bad at it today I drink one of
these every day it's a [ __ ] ton of water
a load of water every day
do some hiking I go on Hikes with my
doggy
Joy enjoys it as well
Joy enjoys it
that's the whole thing like exercising
is easy ish
like lifting weights is fun let's you
know it is fun
maybe not leg day
chest arms are fun
uh back's fun but uh
the real key is what you eat
I eat a lot of [ __ ] apples I just
don't eat that much food
to be honest
there's non on this apple
absolutely rich Joy gets belly rubs
constantly
literally all day every day
what can I put on my club storm stop no
I hate doing arms but you like legs
bruh
you're crazy
diet is much harder
much harder
but you can get into it
a hoe on prom night all shaky like okay
you like being shaky
talk to me two days after your your leg
day
two days later
shut up you stop praying
that's where it gets bad
can't walk anywhere
okay
should we try Ronaldo
I don't know I need to get off soon I
didn't realize how long we've been
streaming for
I think this is a good start
we are gonna be playing little
nightmares little nightmares one
tomorrow
and then little nightmares 2 the next
day and then I might pick this back up
on Thursday and then we're gonna play
scoring on Friday
so I think we'll pick this this back up
on Thursday
I'm just gonna scream a bunch
I can barely get out of bed I feel
accomplished all right if that's what
you like man
that's what you gotta do why is Chad
like way up here
[Music]
should have been like this the whole
time
okay
yeah I think I'm gonna call it there
guys uh it's my dad's birthday today so
say happy birthday Bob we're having a
big party for him on Sunday so I will
not be streaming on Sunday this week
um
we're gonna be setting up for that all
day and then partying our butts off he's
turning 60.
happy birthday Bob Bobby
um
yeah so
my dad's gonna get home in about half an
hour so I'm gonna go hang out with him
tell him happy birthday and give him a
present I got him a book uh anyway
I'm out of here guys appreciate you
listening to me while I ran about [ __ ]
today I really do appreciate it thank
you for listening thanks for all the new
memberships too
um join our Discord I'm probably going
to integrate something into our Discord
I may even possibly make a new Discord
for members only so look out for that
um
I think I'll just I'll make like some
sections in the Discord we'll see
I'll see you guys tomorrow we're playing
little nightmares one tomorrow little
nightmares two the next day we can play
them all in one stream and then we'll
pick this back up on Thursday and then
we got scorn
which I'm really excited about actually
on Friday it's gonna release on Friday
so we'll play it then
have a good one guys
appreciate every single one of you thank
you for all the support you guys are
insane
and I will see you tomorrow
peace dudes bye bye bye
bye bye